[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je m'appelle vincent couronne
et vous avez-vous demandé ce
fellah vous demandez ce que je fais là
parce qu'habituellement quand je parle
j'ai tendance à bégayer mes étudiants le
savent
et puis surtout quand je parle en public
j'ai des trous de mémoire souvent lors
du coup j'ai dû écrire mon discours
sauf qu'avec le stress j'ai tendance à
trembler donc le pas à bord du papier
dans les mains sinon vous imaginer quoi
ça ressemblerait et puis en plus vous
allez vous demander ce que je fais là
parce que ici c'est une conférence sur
le big data et je suis juriste
c'est une conférence ted et pourtant je
n'ai pas de slide mais si je suis là
c'est parce que il y a une idée que je
veux absolument partager avec vous et
alors on va commencer je vais avoir
besoin de vous j'ai posé vous poser une
question lever la main ceux parmi vous
qui ont déjà voté
bon c'est plutôt rassurant
parmi celles qui ont déjà voté levez la
main ceux qui ont déjà été déçu parce
qu'un politique n'aura pas tenu aucune
de ses promesses
voilà ça c'est plus inquiétant pour le
coup et bien écoutez et voyons ce que je
veux dire après parce que ça devrait
vous intéresser
une mise au point d'abord tout ce que je
vais vous dire touche au juridique il
n'est pas question ici d'exprimer une
opinion politique ou plutôt une autre je
vais vous apporter quelques faits
sociaux ou internationaux tenez par
exemple que pensez vous d'un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle qui proposent
de sortir de la zone euro sans quitter
l'union européenne juridiquement c'est
impossible
que pensez vous d'un autre candidat à
l'élection présidentielle qui propose
d'interdire toute activité de lobbying
aux parlementaires partiellement
impossible et d'ailleurs il de la que
partiellement mis en oeuvre mais
regardons un peu plus loin
l'italie la pologne l'autriche
le brésil partout dans le monde des
groupes qui ne croient plus en la
démocratie ou qu'ils en aient rod les
principes arrive au pouvoir et qui en
souffrent ou qui en souffrira au final
c'est moi c'est vous les citoyens
ce sont les citoyens qui peu à peu
renoncent à leur liberté
il y renonce parce que il n'y croit plus
parce qu'ils ne voient plus d'intérêt
peu à peu les citoyens laissent leur
état de droit c'est rodez mais l'état de
droit c'est quoi c'est le fait que nous
tous nous soyons soumis aux droits et
aux mêmes droits
nous tous nous sommes censés respecter
le droit sens et j'imagine très bien
quelqu'un ici qui a pas payé sa place de
parking ce soir mais écoutez quand même
cette contrainte là le fait que nous
sommes tous soumis au droit
elle a un avantage c'est que je répète
tous nous y sommes soumis c'est à dire
des entreprises des syndicats mais aussi
les élus sont soumis au droit
vous imaginez vous un gouvernement qui
serait capable de faire absolument tout
je dis bien absolument tout ce qu'il
veut sans être soumis au droit
si vous êtes ici ce soir c'est bien
parce que vous avez pu sortir de chez
vous marcher librement dans la rue et je
peux exprimer ici mes opinions
c'est grâce au droit si nous sommes ici
ce soir c'est parce que on pourra
tranquillement sortir de cette
conférence tous ensemble à la fin sans
craindre que le monde ait pu changer
radicalement entre temps il ne saura pas
tout d'un coup une manière totalement
arbitraire interdite je sais pas moi de
porter un chapeau de d'exprimer une
opinion d'être d'origine étrangère le
droit c'est l' architecture de la
démocratie sans lui tout s'effondre
alors le citoyen doit pouvoir reprendre
ses droits et avec quels outils
alors maintenant qu'on a joué un petit
peu à se faire peur si vous voulez vous
essayer de se rassurer avec l outil bien
une ressource qui est aussi foisonnante
que précieuse la donner et certains sont
déjà partis bien devant pour ça il ya
pas longtemps j'ai rencontré timothée
timothée c'est un gag incroyable avec
quelques amis timothée il a créé date
agora tagora c'est un site internet qui
agrège des données statistiques
publiques
vous savez les chiffres du chômage les
chiffres de l'immigration où les
résultats d'une élection il les agrège
et les structures et les met à la
disposition du public afin que tous
puissent les comprendre afin que tout le
monde puisse s'assurer qu'on ne lui dit
pas de bêtise
afin que tous puissent réfléchir et
anticiper et puis voter en connaissance
de cause la donnée ça sert à ça aussi ça
sert à pouvoir agir de manière
pertinente et moi dans tout ça
qu'est-ce que je fais là il ya deux ans
avec un ami designer joachim nous avons
créé le site internet
les surligneurs alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait au surligneur on surligne on
surligne discours politique avec le
feutre du droit nous sommes un collectif
de juristes universitaires qui vérifions
le débat public et qui disons à chaque
fois qu en politique fait une erreur dit
quelque chose qui n'est pas en
conformité avec la réalité du droit ou
alors fait une promesse qui est
intenable
nous disons pourquoi et puis nous
expliquons aussi les conséquences si
jamais cette promesse cette promesse
venait être réalisé en deux ans nous
avons publié plusieurs centaines
d'articles et nous travaillons avec des
médias de premier plan
pourtant est-ce que c'est suffisant on
pense que ça ne l'est pas mais on pense
qu'on peut aller plus loin par contre on
pense qu'on peut faire quelque chose
d'encore plus simple plus accessible et
plus démocratique
grâce là encore à la donne et nous
pensons que grâce à la donne et nous
pouvons notamment mesurer l'impact que
ces erreurs ont sur les citoyens
alors de quelle manière je vais vous
surprendre mais d'abord grâce à l'humain
parce que c'est à l'humain de continuer
à dire ce que vous dites est faux et on
vous expliquer pourquoi
ou alors ce que vous promettez est
impossible mais peut-être que une autre
voie est possible
c'est à l'humain de retisser le lien
entre le citoyen et le politique la
donnée ici n'est qu'un outil au service
de ce lien et puis évidemment c'est à
l'humain de garder la maîtrise du droit
et de la démocratie
et puis ont créé un algorithme ont créé
un algorithme capable de mesurer cet
impact des erreurs sur les citoyens
alors on n'est pas dupe nous sommes tous
au courant ici que les algorithmes ne
sont pas neutres ils ont des billets qui
annales qui en altère la sincérité
il faut donc faire en sorte de pouvoir
expurgée de cet algorithme un maximum de
bié alors mesurer la visibilité d'un
propos d'une erreur sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est très facile
l'analyse de données de données fait ça
très bien de nos jours en revanche une
fausse promesse
en matière de retraites si elle est
prononcée pendant une émission au hasard
d'infodivertissement de début de soirée
plutôt pour les jeunes est-ce qu'elle a
plus ou moins de chance ou plus ou moins
d'impact que si elle est prononcée
encore au hasard dans une émission du
dimanche pour un public plus âgé
et oui vous aurez compris il faut
prendre en compte le public
si on veut viser juste et puis faut
faire en sorte que les citoyens gardent
confiance aussi dans cet algorithme de
quelle manière en faisant en sorte qu'il
soit ouvert qui soit ouvert et
transparent afin que tous puissent le
contrôle et le vérifier et qu'on fasse
remonter les critiques pour toujours
plus en expurger les billets si on
arrive à faire en sorte d'expurger un
maximum de biais de cet algorithme
on pourra arriver à faire un classement
des politiques en fonction de la
crédibilité de leur discours et au final
ce qui t'a ce extraordinaire avec ça
c'est que ça va révéler en creux les
choix que nous faisons depuis des
décennies des choix de société
parce que celui qui va se retrouver en
bas du classement pourquoi sera-t-il en
bas du classement parce que nous avons
fait des choix depuis des décennies par
exemple pourquoi ne peut-on pas revenir
sur l'asile pourquoi ne peut-on pas
revenir sur la présomption d'innocence
pourquoi ne peut-on pas supprimer ou
priver quelqu'un de sa propriété sans
raison valable
ces choix ce classement va dessiner en
creux aussi les choix que nous faisons
dans notre démocratie et qui permettent
et qui sont aussi susceptibles de
changer
inquiet sur la capacité de nos
démocraties à pouvoir passer ce cap que
nous vivons en ce moment parce que mon
expérience d'enseignant me montre que
les jeunes aujourd'hui sont plus aptes à
s'engager qui hier grâce aux réseaux
sociaux
les groupes s'organisent et se structure
pour s'engager
et si on écoute le philosophe edgar
morin vous savez celui qui avait prédit
mai 68
edgar morin dit aujourd'hui que il voit
poindre de nouvelles solidarités de
nouvelles manières de s'engager
grâce aux réseaux sociaux et on le voit
tous les jours mais beaucoup de ceux qui
sont sur les réseaux sociaux ne savent
pas comment s'engager avec les
surligneurs nous leur proposons de faire
un pari sur l'avenir
parce qu au surligneur non seulement on
aiderait les citoyens mais en plus de ça
on aide le politique parce qu'au lieu de
déterminer ses positions en fonction de
sondages qu'il commet la tour de bras et
d'ailleurs auquel nous avons que très
peu accès et qui utilise la donne est
aussi là ce classement on le met sur la
place publique au vu et au su de tous y
compris de ses politiques en pénalise la
démagogie et on valorise la raison mais
nous y trompons pas cet algorithme doit
être ouvert aussi parce que ce qui est
faux endroit n'est pas forcément faux en
économie ou n'est pas forcément faux en
sociologie à voiron d'algorithmes ouvert
permettra à tous de sorte de s'en saisir
et de construire ses propres
raisonnement et ses propres classement
en fonction de ça dit ce type de sa
discipline et la fondée sur la raison
nous pouvons avoir vrai débat
démocratique
alors maintenant il faut passer à
l'action et pour construire tout cela
nous avons besoin de chercheurs des
mathématiciens certes et des juristes
bien sûr mais nous avons besoin aussi
pour dénicher tous ces biais de
chercheur en communication des
linguistes des neuroscientifiques et
puis si vous avez été convaincus que le
droit est vraiment centrale dans nos
démocraties et que les démocraties sont
en danger par les entrants autour de
vous parler des surligneurs partager nos
articles ils sont pour tout le monde
allez voir dates agora ce qu'ils font
est formidable
la donnée n'a pas à être une ressource
utilisée par quelques entreprises de la
silicon valley qui font du profit sur
notre vie privée ou par quelques groupes
qui veulent influencer les votes
j'espère que vous aurez compris que la
donner lorsqu'elle est utilisée par et
pour le citoyen peut améliorer la
politique et donc l'avenir pour le
meilleur n'oubliez jamais la démocratie
c'est le pouvoir du peuple par le peuple
et pour le peuple et pour une fois dans
l'histoire c'est peut-être possible
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]